welcome back everybody this is the
dragon ball fighters world tour final
Tenkaichi event here at first attack
Puerto Rico
I am Romanova yeah this is gonna be a
great tournament top a is super super
stacked we had a ton of killers coming
out from all over the world to compete
here in the top hey it's gonna be a
great one so far as you mentioned I
think it's very important to say the
last 10k each event on the stop we just
have to saga events left before the
World Tour Finals which should be a lot
of fun so you know I'm really excited
for this there's a lot of people in this
top a who need points we're really
struggling to get that last little bit
and squeeze in there so I'm excited for
it and to the people on the stage are
people who I'm sure would love to have
some points and are very familiar with
each other as players as well oh
definitely
so this is kind of a match of friends
here from the west coast we have apology
man in super noon apology man checking
his hair making sure it survived the
humidity I'm sure oh yeah you know he is
ready to go he is like you were saying
earlier to the currency yeah if he wins
this he's gonna have to he's gonna yeah
he's gonna have to go to the bank and be
like hey whatever Puerto Rican pesos I
won for winning can I turn that to USD
cuz I don't know what currency I got for
winning this thing but I need to make
sure I have it he asked you if you spoke
Porto Rican earlier yeah yeah I said
King woman dia and he was like yeah I
didn't know you can speak quirt o Rican
I see he's an educated man very educated
educated and well travel
he's been all over the world a really
really strong player and he's spelling
up again super noon first these two
played each other a lot and you
mentioned West Coast matchup yeah norcal
socal this is a pretty standard stuff
and on the other side we have to SoCal
players in winter side top a it so all
players from California in winter side
top eight of this bracket which is
insane when you consider that you know
you have players like na Kiel and sage
and wah wah and shanks and Pasha Kawa
and all these really really strong
killers from all over the world so it's
it's an interesting topping the way
shaky now especially in winter side I
think absolutely and you were talking
about points to one of the things that I
think was really important to note here
was tachikoma making top eight I know
that there have been a little bit of
team struggles like figuring out a team
and his team that he has now seems to
have been the one that works and got him
into this top eight here on the looser
sides
- yeah watching him lose the freezer
though and winters was a little
disheartening right I was like oh come
on man
it was karma that's karma is it yes it's
like he couldn't quit him he's I can't
quit you and then once he did Frieza
came back from the grave and I was like
hold up like well don't actually quote
me because it's probably not that many
but I'm gonna be dramatic here and be
like how many times is Frieza been
resurrected it just seems like Frieza
always comes back we're always coming
back you know yeah probably nothing
anyway one of the things that I think
we're gonna see here a lot saij am with
the apology man's game plan is the we're
gonna see a lot with a snap snap meta
well yeah I mean the interesting thing
about apology man and how he builds his
game plan in every game is that the goal
is at least the like the minimum
interaction with your opponent is
possible right it's like get a hit snap
you force you to block like you know
this makes up that straight fifty-fifty
if you get hit snap again and just run
that mix-up right like the goal is if
you make one mistake or if he gets one
good hit in neutral then the match
should snowball in a way that puts him
in a bit like a huge life advantage gets
a character killed forces out your
sparking it's it's really to put you on
the back foot immediately his team is
really really good at doing that yeah
his team's very impressive especially
thriving in the corner yeah as soon as
you get hit in the corner fuzzies all
day you just get snapped over and over
every combo builds one meter and then
it's just you know he spends it vanish
snap or he just drops you into an assist
it's bad news go first match of this top
a here super do versus apology man gets
clipped by that cheesy go with this and
already in the corner blocking 2l gets
stopped early hit for super noon
absolutely and this is like the
positioning that you want to have you
want to make quick work of piccolo as
soon as you can if you're super noon in
this match
almost got the hit there did not confirm
yeah you see delays on the string that's
a punish even though the air blog has
time to get on the ground at 2m that's a
big punish but the main thing about this
is like for super noon he's staggering
and trying to delay his string so he
could build as a sis back in the corner
there level three early a lot of damage
potentially ports early spark but I
don't know yet
yeah you see that's why you backed off
waiting to try to see if he was going to
spark out of there dragon rush broken
and that's your as the MF of the class H
mystic ball apology man's in trouble oh
yeah this is gonna be a dead teen gohan
and he is out of there
yes mother Durley and this is huge right
if you can cut off part of the team gave
her the assist early it's such a big win
you know you piccolo Goku is a really
solid shell but losing that character
early is definitely rough or apology man
counter super dance there bring in GT
Goku doesn't want anything to do with
that be missus yeah I'm gonna string him
up oh the grab yeah MP Lodi Blanca first
part of the mix-up but that's a pretty
standard option after with a lot of
piccolo players reflects off Marlon was
gonna hit the double overhead with the
jump L to the combo but yeah he was
ready for that tag I think he backed up
probably expecting it or not wanting to
go ahead air with piccolo through the
key blast here piccolo yeah goes to went
low and you block the gumball mix-ups
mark yeah I don't blame him
piccolo gets it there he's dead and then
you know the chance of winning pretty
rough after that I think yeah you
definitely don't want anything to do
with me in the corner against the kid
fooball locking you down that gumball is
relentless yeah we're off super dad and
this might be the opening that Hawking
and he did when he drops bad that's a
huge drop string him up gumball no
reflect that wasn't a real block string
but gets hit low sparks up and I agree I
think you have to kill this piccolo here
you know he doesn't have sparking left
anyway yeah air to H I love that combo
choice nice and simple from super noon
javelin to get the job done
yeah now apology man does have a really
good Super Saiyan Goku don't get me
wrong he has been playing this character
for a very long time but him without
piccolo is just it's just not the same
apology man that we would normally see
right yeah and this about to being to
snap so that you don't have to deal with
any assists or anything that's a good
choice I think but just clean be damage
from super noon drop it I think route is
a little finicky but when the punish on
that with that too age that is gonna be
a dead Super Saiyan Goku and it looks
like game one here is going to yeah
cleaned up I mean you know that's the
way you want to play this kind of a
matchup we talked about it earlier but
the main thing about piccolo and this
team in general is the little
interactions that you get into in the
beginning of the match are so important
because if piccolo gets to hit it right
away
it could be over so you know I think
smothering him early and forcing out
spar forcing out kills on characters
that's really important in a matchup
like this it's just scary because if
round start you don't get the hit it
might turn around like if this is like
air - back jump Allen he hits you or
something you might die right away right
and you could just be the end of the
match we saw earlier - when apology man
was playing to kill sage now to kill
sage has told me that he is one of his
demons in tournament and he normally
doesn't win against apology man and it
was that corner you know its positioning
that him and just kept being so
oppressive
it just gets wrong every time here we go
we might get a glimpse of it here
against super noon he has a block in the
beginning the banishes out no meter to
counter vanish for apology man gonna
string him up doesn't have his
assistance yet and barkas is available
super - in but nice call out Paul you
been really good by playing by an epic
Louis this drop combo though yeah that's
bean drop kind of hurts a little bit
we're taking in kid foo gonna get that
heavy link there yeah I think one thing
we've seen a lot is a lot of people have
switched it to Gohan
the game right that was a sick on board
of the dragon run [ __ ] piccolo or put
a lot of drops from this character for
people who have just picked them up
right I think it's definitely part of
the growing pains of lending a new
character like this oh yeah I mean there
are certain ways of playing them right
like simpler ways but if you want a
really mascot character wow that to H on
piccolo coming in yeah good call out
early topology man and the start of this
so I like that super noon was ready for
it again
all right forcing the mix-up off the
gumball no reflect any sparks out did
not want anything again to do with that
oh the brief black and the punished on
that yeah big damage here sparking head
wit T go on and a lot of you to spend
for apology man gonna be clean super
noon sparks yeah I think that's a good
choice given the situation you probably
want to give up Kid Buu and one mix-up
for free after you lost all that life
that's what you gotta do some people
won't make a move when they see those
legs out there but you know good for
super noon for calling that out gonna be
a little one level one for the kill
oh yeah that's great you know they both
traits parkings but a big win of super
noon to get the kill right there apology
man with a lot of meters so I think
basically his Bardock or whatever
character he hits next to probably one
punch kill now if apology make a move
here this is still really good for him
these are two of his characters he's
been playing the longest there we go and
there's the opening that he needed we're
gonna take him to the corner yeah that's
the kill more than a meter combo that
yeah drop well ran under dragon rush he
was hitting in that little GT Goku body
it's gonna be big spend the meter and
he's gonna extend go for the triple
level one for the kill Oh II didn't even
check out it's blue nah
[Music]
socks I didn't see cursed that might hit
both no this is the one and that's the
punishment look at the blue life on par
talk though if Kabbalah Japan gets a hit
he's got Sam that is yeah that would be
a good time to snap especially if that
he just needs to find that opening
though yeah any hit okay because you
want to stamp in Bartok and then
probably bring in Kid Buu and both those
characters behind one hit but you see
super ninjas waiting he knows what the
blue lights coming back no reason to get
crazy through they're trying to reflect
it yeah I got caught wiggling and it's
gonna be lots of time lost spirit bomb
first one of the poppy hold your hands
up Genki dama time get to see those
molars drama we'll see what the mix it's
gonna be weighted I think you're trying
to call reflect or maybe reversal level
three I think so also so unfortunately
even get that blue light that we're
talking about earlier
Oh tries to go for the jump heavy denied
Nash trigger mob class reverse class
though yeah that was a good try from
super noon and the to a genuine hit the
deck extension doing super new winners
finals
oh man said easy man he was like wait
wait how do I lose he's like wow it's so
easy I don't really remember I'll be
honest sounds great
my dad said easy didn't even motion a
pop off just said easy that's
cold-blooded you're gonna do that while
you're still sitting next to them could
you imagine it's that easy in the vini
it's like what how do I even get here
well let me explain what happened was
let me just break it down for you there
is a reflect and then you got smoke and
then it be like that so that's a first
set of top in a quick one